quand j'étais jeune en cinquième je me
serais toujours de lui ça plaît antonin
comment ce marathonien déjà ah ouais
ouais antonin oui quand même mais moi
j'étais jeune mais en général avec al
qaïda pour s'appeler automne non non il
était 5e pareil donc on a un cinquième
en aqua 13 ans ouais sauf que moi
j'étais assez chétif jusqu'à l'âge de
16-17 ça fait plusieurs fois que vous
nous le dites oui absolument et donc
j'ai tendance est un peu tête de turc et
je n'osais pas retourner à l'école face
à cette rentrée me faisait peur mon père
qui est de bon conseil me dit dès le
premier jour shop le plus gros est
costaud antonin en l'occurrence tu lui
rentrer dedans et tout le reste de
l'année comme en prison tu seras
respecter tout le temps des fêtes en
prison non mais j'ai déjà vu des films
c'est un peu la loi du plus fort
d'accord donc est ce que j'ai fait le
premier jour non non je suis allé là et
bam non c'est exprès de l'est le
chauffer j'ai fait exprès les chauffer
pourquoi vous l'aï dit quoi joue banon
je suis passé à côté comme ça va je
passais à côté de l'espace ou les deux
mais
doucement parce que tu as tendance à
être un petit peu tutu chahutent
[Applaudissements]
shalit est discutée la disant tu
discutes avec quelqu'un ouais
moi je suis passé j'ai fait ça tunisie
ou plus au [ __ ] j'ai fait sabam ouais
donc l'audi s'est retourné mais ils
savent pas mais j'ai rien senti dont
pourtant j'ai tout mais
alors je leur fais mais prend pas ça
pour une démonstration de force assure
je m'excuse pas et était surtout un
effet wow wow oh ouais alors est comment
et commence à me dire tu va bousculer
qui m'a bousculé tu m'a bousculé et là
j'ai fait et qu'est ce ça peut te [ __ ]
donc là c'est comme ça que ça petit de
ce
réseau est surpris à reculer et surpris
alors additionnel c'est pas très costaud
ça laisse un peu trop collant oui à tout
le monde d'où ce qu'une antonin c'était
quand même et anthony wayne rooney
c'était le seul petit moment de ma
fierté est ce que là et après il est
revenu ouais et je me serai toujours
derrière moi il me fait comme ça par ma
femme il m'a pris comme ça là il m'a
baissé comme ainsi la non non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il m'a dit m'a pris pas de coups comme
dans jury je vais le retrouver elana qui
m'a fait un peu corée mais il m'a fait
ça comme ça et là paf non deux
comme ça
et là
il ya eu une agression a bailar
ya du vrai chef
et alors tu largeur du coup cela a fait
l'effet inverse toute l'année il tâta
pays bas j'ai été le bien où je m'étais
fait casser la gueule dès le premier
jour
3com du courage oui mais on sait pas
vraiment battu mon ami 2 je suis tombé y
aurait eu une bagarre oui mais tu y
aller ouais franchement macro temps avec
toi là j'ai résisté
je l'aï ce match à lyon je vais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]